hey gun owner Brian here if like me and
I hope you're like me you are staying
inside you are hunkered down avoiding
contact with other people and being safe
well you're probably bored right now a
lot of us are let's face it we're
looking for something to do
guess what's very popular at the moment
that's right I think some of you just
said it jigsaw puzzles I prefer the old
thousand-piece puzzle myself but I want
to be careful there's a thousand pieces
in here each one could possibly be
infected that's why I'm gonna take this
very simple precaution and I suggest you
do as well and I'm going to boil them
boil each piece what you want to do is
really stir it around
I suggest you sing the Happy Birthday
song for every puzzle piece
that's the Happy Birthday song 1000
times happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear
possible piggies happy birthday to you
that's one happy a birthday not cool
so you can add different sort of accents
happy birthday to you all right that was
1,000 times it's been three and a half
days I'm soaked in urine pieces flip
there we go let cool let it cool you can
start trying to put the pieces
where they that's really hot not sure
what that used to be really sometimes
yeah that's a problem well makes it more
challenging you got to put these pieces
down first and then match them to the
piece that washed away so in a way it's
not become a ten thousand piece jigsaw
puzzle well hope this helped I'm sure it
did I've got work to do I got a work to
do